-Hello, everyone,
and welcome back
to another edition
of "Late Night"
in a makeshift home studio.
And as you can see, we're
trying yet another location
in my house.
We had been shooting
in a garage,
but we abandoned that
because it was so cold
that by the end of Monday's
"Closer Look,"
my nose was redder
than a cartoon drunk.
I mean, look at that thing.
It was like
"Late Night with Andy Capp."
No, I never would have made
an Andy Capp reference
in front of a live audience
because silence
would have been deafening,
but these days that's
the reaction to everything.
So I figured, you know,
why not let it rip?
So today we're giving it a shot
from a crawl space in the attic,
and when I told my 4-year-old
Daddy was going up to the attic
for a while, he said
the cutest thing.
"If you and Mom are getting
a divorce, just tell us."
Kids, right?
And it looks like I'll be doing
these shows from home
for a while now that
the president has extended
the social distancing guidelines
to the end of April
while he and allies try
to memory-hole
their early dismissal
of the coronavirus outbreak.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Donald Trump has tried
repeatedly to claim
that no one could have seen
this crisis coming,
even though he was
repeatedly warned
in intelligence briefings
in January and February
that it was coming.
In fact, the "New York Times"
reported Tuesday
that White House economists
published a study
last September that warned
a pandemic disease could kill
a half million Americans
and devastate the economy.
It went unheeded inside
the administration.
"Unheeded" is a generous
description.
In reality, what probably
happened was an economist
put the study
on Trump's desk and said,
"Sir, you should read this,"
and he said,
"What is it, nerd?"
And then the economist said,
"It's about a possible
pandemic."
And Trump said,
"What's a pandemic, Poindexter?"
And then the economist said,
"A pandemic is when
a disease spreads,"
and before he could finish,
Trump was asleep on his desk
with a Burger King wrapper
stuck to his face.
Probably.
And of course it went unheeded.
Trump doesn't heed.
He doesn't heed the law.
He doesn't heed advice.
And he especially doesn't
heed studies.
In fact, he makes it
actively harder
for everyone else
to heed studies.
For example, at his press
conference Tuesday night,
he turned the mic over
to task force coordinator
Dr. Deborah Birx, who took
the room of reporters
through a series of important
slides of valuable data,
and Trump just wandered over
and stood right in front
of the screen.
"Hey, man, we're trying to read.
Get out of the way."
"Should I stand right here
in front of the screen
so you can't read it?
Is that helpful, Dr. Birx?
Dr. Birx?
Maybe I'll stand in front of the
part that represents the time
I should have done something
when I didn't do anything?
What do you think, Fauci?
Oh, oh, I got you again, Fauci.
I got you to touch
your face again.
Oh, this is my favorite game,
Fauci, and I always win.
I'm just kidding, we're pals.
Trump and Fauci,
the original Lenny and Squiggy.
That's what people say."
Seriously, man, the only reason
anyone tunes in to
these briefings
is to hear the
scientists.
They're the feature
presentation.
You're a dancing box of popcorn
singing --
♪ Let's go out to the lobby ♪
♪ Let's go out
to the lobby ♪
♪ Let's go out to the lobby ♪
♪ And ignore this
terrifying data ♪
And that wasn't the only warning
the Trump administration got.
In fact, before Trump
even took office,
President Obama's outgoing team
tried to prepare Trump
and his aides for a scenario
exactly like this one.
-Days before Donald Trump
took office,
some of President Obama's
advisers
walked the incoming
president's team
through a hypothetical scenario
remarkably like the one
we're living through now.
It was a briefing on what would
happen if a quick-spreading
virus were to race through
London and Seoul,
and in that scenario
they presented governments
imposing travel bans,
there were shortages at
hospitals across the country,
and today, roughly two-thirds of
those Trump administration
officials who participated
in that simulation
are no longer in government.
-Of course they aren't.
This administration runs through
employees faster
than an ice cream shop
on the Coney Island Boardwalk.
Someone should have run
a simulation for what happens
when an egomaniac fires
every staff member
who ever disagrees with him.
"After three years,
the simulation does show
it will be down to you,
a professional liar,
and a Victorian-era
teenage ghost."
I mean, Trump has had four,
four Chiefs of Staff
in four years, and the current
one, Mark Meadows,
officially started
on the job yesterday.
Man, what a time to start
working for this White House.
"All right, show me
to my new office."
"I can't, it's been turned
into a field hospital.
Also, you're the
surgeon general now."
And what's his next move,
zookeeper
at Joe Exotic's animal park?
And even if the officials
in that briefing were still
in government, I bet they didn't
learn anything anyway
because Trump was standing
directly in front of the screen.
So Trump had many warnings
that something like this
was coming,
and yet he and his aides
repeatedly downplayed
or dismissed the threat.
He said cases would
go down to zero,
that it would miraculously
disappear,
and compared it to the flu
even though coronavirus
is much more infectious
and much deadlier.
-This is a flu.
This is like a flu.
You treat this like a flu.
It's a little like the regular
flu that we have flu shots for.
And we'll essentially have
a flu shot for this
in a fairly quick manner.
The flu in our country
kills from 25,000 people
to 69,000 people a year.
That was shocking to me.
Over the last ten years,
we've lost 360,000.
These are people
that have died from the flu,
from what we call the flu.
-What do you mean,
what we call the flu?
It's the flu.
We all call it the flu.
Trump talks about regular words
like they're complicated
medical jargon.
"We in the scientific community
call it the flu.
It's called that because it
started over in Europe
and then it flew here."
Also basically everything he
said in that clip was wrong.
Turns out you aren't
an expert in science
just because you look like
a science experiment.
He's like a bunch of body parts
a dead gangster
has sewn together
and brought to life
by a guy who went to school
with Dr. Frankenstein
but dropped out
sophomore year.
I can just see him
being tormented by villagers
with torches --
"Ah, fire bad,
but not that bad, basically
the same as the flu.
Ah!"
Trump should be in a documentary
where Jane Goodall
teaches him
sign language.
"Donald, can you say the words
'distribution emergency'?"
-Distribution evergency.
-And then less than a month ago,
Trump tweeted,
"So last year 37,000 Americans
died from the common flu.
It averages between 27,000
and 70,000 per year.
Nothing is shut down.
Life and the economy go on.
At this moment there are
546 confirmed cases
of coronavirus
with 22 deaths.
Think about that."
Any time a world-renowned idiot
like Donald Trump
tells you to think about that,
that's your cue
to exit the conversation.
He's like the dumbest guy
at a cocktail party
trying to make conversation
by telling you
something he read
on a Snapple cap.
"Broccoli, you know, only
vegetable that's also a flower,
so, that's something
to think about."
Of course, the lie that
coronavirus is just like the flu
did obvious damage.
You know how many people heard
that and then repeated it?
Even if you hated Donald Trump
and knew not to trust
a word he said,
everyone had
that one friend or relative
on the text chain who said,
"You know, it's
not going to be so bad.
It's going to be like the flu."
Or I should say,
"It's going to be like
what we call the flu."
And now that his White House is
projecting as many as 100,000
to 200,000 deaths
from the coronavirus,
Trump has once again
shifted his tone.
-I've had many friends,
businesspeople,
people with great actually
common sense,
they said,
"Why don't we ride it out?"
A lot of people have said, a lot
of people have thought about it,
"Ride it out, don't do anything,
just ride it out
and think of it as the flu."
But it's not the flu.
It's vicious.
-You're the one who said
it was the flu.
Those friends of yours were you.
Or more likely, your other
personalities.
That's serious Trump,
angry Trump, sweaty Trump,
and silly Trump.
"And they all told me
this is just like the flu.
Silly Trump even said it with
an old-timey car horn.
[ Horn honks ]
[ Laughs ]
Oh, Silly Trump,
you're incorrigible."
And then Trump tried to claim
that despite repeatedly
ignoring the problem,
failing to surge
hospital capacity,
and falling behind
on testing which inhibited
our ability to trace
and quarantine cases
the way South Korea did,
his administration actually
deserved credit for bringing
the projected death toll
down to only 100,000
to 200,000.
-What do the models suggest
is on the low end
if you have full mitigation?
-It says 100,000 to 200,000.
Anything -- it's a lot
of people, right?
It's a lot of people.
Well, you didn't ask
the other question --
What would have happened --
because this is the question
that I've been asking Dr. Fauci
and Dr. Birx for a long time,
and they've been working
on this for a long time --
The question is, what would have
happened if we did nothing?
-That is what you did.
You did nothing,
and you do nothing.
You work less than CBD oil.
And doing nothing is the only
thing you're good at.
Even when you had your own game
show, you were only on it
for like five minutes
at the end.
You were Alex Trebek if he only
showed up for Final Jeopardy!
"Let's take a look at those
scores, and, yikes,
looks like someone doesn't know
their potent potables."
And really it's a shame
you're president right now
because both you're deeply
ill-equipped for the job
and because if you weren't
president,
you would have been great
at quarantine.
All you'd have to do is
sit at home, order takeout,
watch TV, and tweet
like the rest of us,
and those are all
your favorite things.
You would have killed it
in quarantine.
President Hillary Clinton would
have held you up as an example
of how to do social distancing.
"We all have to follow the
advice of doctors
and stay at home,
just like Donald Trump,
who is currently sitting
in his pajamas
watching a rerun of "Maury"
and tweeting,
"Colonel Sanders should be
promoted to General Sanders.
He is a national hero."
And yet, because he managed to
restrain himself for an hour
after weeks of lies
and serial failures
that led us to this
harrowing moment,
some in the media were actually
gullible enough
after four years
to give Trump credit
for his change of tone.
-President Trump just moments
ago with a somber tone.
-Now, for his part,
and this gets to the tone
and demeanor change,
Trump warned that the
next two weeks would be tough.
-It was a very sober president
that we saw.
-The president did strike
a very somber tone
in his latest briefing.
-This was a different
Donald Trump tonight.
-My God, these people could be
fooled by Jeffrey Dahmer.
"This is not Jeffrey Dahmer
the crazed murderer.
This was a more serious Dahmer,
just quietly home-cooking
a meal for one."
Of course it was a different
Donald Trump.
It's a different Donald Trump
every night, which means
it's always the same
Donald Trump.
He never fundamentally changes
who he is as a person.
He just swings wildly
back and forth
from one extreme
to the other.
He's like a werewolf but for
the sun instead of the moon.
But Trump isn't the only one
trying to memory-hole
his initial response
to the crisis.
There's also one of his closest
and most loyal defenders on TV,
Sean Hannity.
A few weeks ago,
Hannity tried to claim
he was taking the
situation seriously.
And on Monday he actually
accused others in the media
of spreading
conspiracy theories.
-This program has always taken
the coronavirus seriously.
And we've never called
the virus a hoax.
How does anyone trust the
outright conspiracy theorists,
that whole network full of lies,
conspiracy theories?
-Dude, all you do is
spread conspiracy theories.
You're like Alex Jones without
the brain pills.
In fact, you should probably
take some.
Your network spent years
promoting
insane conspiracy theories
from death panels
to birtherism to
nonexistent voter fraud.
Fox has even interviewed
an actual lizard person.
And in particular,
in this particular case,
Hannity lined up behind Trump
during his early claim
that the coronavirus
was no big deal,
using the word "hoax"
to describe criticism
of Trump's response
and even suggesting at one point
that it might be a deep-state
plot to destroy the economy.
-They are now sadly
politicizing and actually
weaponizing an infectious
disease,
in what is basically
just the latest effort
to bludgeon President Trump.
They're scaring the living hell
out of people.
And I see it again as, like,
"Oh, let's bludgeon Trump
with this new hoax."
There's an MIT guy I noticed
on Twitter, he said, quote,
"Coronavirus fearmongering
by the deep state will go down
in history as one of the biggest
frauds to manipulate economies,
suppress dissent, and push
mandated medicines."
May be true.
-You're not a news show
if you end your segment
with "May be true."
That's a tagline
you get at 2:00 A.M.
after one of those shows
about ancient aliens
teaching the Aztecs
how to grow grain.
"May be true.
Probably bull [bleep]."
Seriously, we should get
Trump in there
to stand in front of
Hannity during a show.
So one more time, side by side,
here is Sean Hannity.
-They're scaring the living
hell out of people,
and I see it again as like,
"Oh, let's bludgeon Trump
with this new hoax."
This program has always taken
the coronavirus seriously
and we've never called the virus
a hoax.
-Man, that takes some balls.
If Donald Trump turned out to be
an incredible president
who brought the country
together, I'd eat my words.
I wouldn't sit here and swear
that I never once said
he should be in a documentary
where Jane Goodall teaches him
sign language.
Trump should be in a documentary
where Jane Goodall
teaches him sign language.
No, sure, I mean, yeah, when you
cut it together like that.
The president and his allies
wasted precious weeks
when we could have been
preparing for this crisis.
We saw it coming.
We could have ramped up testing
and hospital capacity,
quarantined and traced cases
to contain the spread.
Now we're facing the prospect
of a horrible tragedy.
And when the time for
accountability comes,
Trump should be removed
from office...
-In a fairly quick manner.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Stay safe. Wash your hands.
We love you.